we're on problem 14 problem 14.
if the function f is defined by
f of x
is equal to x squared plus bx
plus c
where b and c are positive constants
which of the following could be the
graph of f
so b and c are positive so what what
does that tell us so
a couple of things you immediately know
the x squared term
whatever is the coefficient on x squared
that tells us whether the parabola opens
up
or opens down it opens up if the
coefficient on the x term is positive
which it is it's positive 1 right so we
know the graph is going to open up it's
not going to be a
downward opening graph like that so we
know the graph is going to look like a u
as opposed to i don't know an intersect
i don't know what this is an a without
the line whatever so we know it's going
to be a u and what else do we know about
it what do we know about its y-intercept
well this is the y-intercept when x is
equal to zero
f of zero is equal to what these two
terms are going to be zero so f of zero
is equal to c
and so we know that the y-intercept is
positive so let's see if we can
if that alone allows us to solve the
problem
so we know that
we know that
the y-intercept is positive so when f of
0 is going to intersect some place on
the positive y-axis
and we know that it's an upward opening
graph so the graph could look like
could look like this
could look like that
it could also look like
well this b term i won't get too much
into the intuition of the b term and so
it actually
we actually know that it is shifted to
the left but
based on just what i said that it's
opening upwards and that it has a
positive y-intercept
you know this this would have also been
a legitimate graph
anything that is opening upwards like a
u
because this is a positive x squared
here
and intersects the y axis in the
positive area would be a correct answer
and if you look at the choices a opens
down that's not the right answer b opens
down not the right answer c
intercepts the y axis at 0 so that's not
the right answer d
opens up but it intersects the y axis
and the negative y
and then finally e is very similar to
what i drew in yellow so that is our
answer
e
next problem
almost finished with this section
okay they drew us a cube
let me draw it big because this looks
like it might involve
some fancy
see let me draw the cube so this is the
front face
whoops
hit undo
all my time is spent drawing drawing
diagrams
cube
drawing a diagram then
goes back like that
i should always draw the back first it
gets good enough i think you get the
point and then you know it draws the
dotted lines maybe i'll draw that later
if i have to
okay
so they tell us that this is point a
and that this right here is point b
they say the cube shown above has edges
of length two so each of these sides are
two each of these sides are two two two
two
two and so on
and a and b are midpoints of the two
edges so a
and b are midpoints so this side is
equal to this side so if the whole side
is equal to 2 and this a is the midpoint
then we know that this is 1 this is 1
this is 1 this is 1. right
okay what is the length of a b
so this is what they want us to figure
out they want us to figure out
they want to draw it in kind of a darker
color no that's not a dark of that line
this is a pure visualization problem at
first you're like boy that's you know
it's three dimensions it's crazy what am
i going to do
you're going to have to do is do the
pythagorean theorem twice
so what do we know
well we know well we know everything we
need to solve this problem let's see if
we can do it so let me draw
that bottom surface
the bottom surface of the cube
so i'll ask you a question can we figure
out so let me draw a line along the
bottom surface let's say that this line
i'm drawing is along the bottom surface
of the cube so i'm going to draw
i'm going to draw this line
that's along the bottom surface of the
cube and let me
label this side like this it's actually
a really fun problem
i'll do this in yellow
so can we figure out what that that
magenta dotted line's length is
well sure we know that
we know first of all you know that is a
right triangle the way i drew it right i
can redraw it like this where this is
yellow
brown
and then dotted line magenta right
all i did is well
right all i did is i i kind of flipped
it up so that you could see it
so what is that we know that brown
length we know that's one
we know the yellow length is what it's
two right because all the sides of the
cube are two
so we use the pythagorean theorem to
figure out the magenta line so it's the
square root it's you know 1 squared
plus 2 squared is equal to this side
squared so we can just take the square
root of it
so that equals the square root of 5
right 1
plus 4 square root of 5 is this magenta
line so the magenta line is square root
of 5.
so now can we figure out that gray line
that i drew at first
well sure because now
now we have another right triangle that
gray line is just the hypotenuse of this
right triangle that's kind of you know
at an angle so let me make sure you
understand what i'm saying
if i were to flatten it out i have this
green side right here
i have this
dotted line base
and then i have the gray line
which is the hypotenuse
right and just so you know what this
point right here would be a and then
this point right here would be b
and do we know the sides
yes we do
we know this green line here is one so
this side here is one i'm just redrawing
it here we know the magenta dotted line
at the bottom which i kind of switched
colors a bit but we just figured out
that that magenta bottom line is square
root of 5.
so now we can just use the pythagorean
theorem
to figure out the length of this line
the length of this line
squared is going to be equal to the
square root of 5 squared plus 1 squared
so the hypotenuse squared is equal to
this so we can take the square root of
that
so that equals the square root of what's
the square root of 5 squared well it's
just 5 right
plus 1. so it's equal to the square root
of 6.
so this line is equal to the square root
and that is choice d we luckily have not
made a mistake
last problem
problem 16
let
x with this kind of oval looking thing
around it be defined as
x squared minus x
for all values of x
if
a
so they're telling us that
a is equal to
a minus 2
what is the value of a
so what does this mean a kind of with
this oval well that just means that a
squared
minus a right
that maps to that just like that and
what does a minus two map do and i'm
just bringing the equal sign down
a minus 2 maps to
every place where i see an x i put an a
minus 2 in there so that equals a minus
2 squared
minus
a minus 2. and now we just keep solving
and most of solving is on the right hand
side so let's see that equals
that equals
a
a squared minus four a
plus four minus a
plus two
so we get a squared
minus a
is equal to
a squared
minus five a right 4a minus 4a minus a
plus 6.
could subtract a from both sides a
squared from both sides right
let me add 5a to both sides
so 5a so you get 4 a is equal to 6.
divide both sides by 4.
you get a is equal to 6 over 4 which
equals one and a half or three halves
and that is choice c
and we are done this section i'll see
you in the next practice test